it all stems from the name of the Moon
that the company building is located on
71 gordion gordion is the name of the
capital of ancient friia and its most
notable King was a man named Midas as in
everything King Midas touches turns to
gold golden King Midas the company
monster that consumes anything offered
to it is on a moon named after the
golden King Midas and the legend of the
golden Planet dictates that it was eaten
by the Beast the man beyond the wall
also claims that he end quote they are
inside the Beast and he's inside Jeb so
here's the hypothesis what if Jeb is the
Beast that ate the golden planet and the
golden planet is what we're standing on
71 Gordon